this worm belongs to the Terra bellad
order but it's known as a spaghetti worm
these tropical worms live in sand
building tubes out of gravel and
Limestone to live in their tentacles
spill out from the tube sometimes
extending as far as a meter to gather
building materials and food for the worm
to reproduce spaghetti worms will
release their eggs and sperm into the
water but only at night and sometimes
even without other males or females
around they seem to do this on a lunar
cycle with a limited two-week window for
those gametes to release and find each
other that seems like an extraordinarily
chancy way to reproduce but it seems to
work for this worm